bonjour patrick wolf merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
la france qui mise sur le tuvalu
vaccinale illustration d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui avec le coup d'envoi de la
vaccination des 5 11 ans tu es dans le
même temps l'om est ce cet après midi
qui dit je cite aucun pays ne pourra se
sortir de la pandémie à coups de dose de
rappel c'est le serpent qui se mord la
queue non à quand la fin de cette
pandémie de kobe de 19
pendant cette rien le virus est là de
façon durable sur notre pays sur tout le
monde il va falloir qu'il s'intègre
petit à petit dans notre patrimoine
immunitaire et pour paul l'aider à
s'intégrer notre patrimoine limitèrent
la vaccination est un outil important
parce qu'il va faciliter la rencontre
qu'on aura tous avec ce public parce
qu'on a tous se rencontrer une fois deux
fois trois fois et il vaut mieux qu'on
va le rencontrer d'être vacciné parce
qu'on aura un coude avant sur ce virus
parce que nous serons déjà porteurs
d'anticorps qui vont nous protéger
de façon importante voire sont moins
importants de façon faibles chez des
pertes n personne par exemple les
personnages et les gens immunodéprimés
mais quand même c'est pas comme s'il
n'avait pas de défense du tout donc je
crois que c'est important actuellement
en plus des mesures barrières des de
respect des mesures barrières c'est de
se vacciner parce que ça nous permet
d'avoir un renforcement de notre imiter
quand on va rencontrer le virus
hier gabriel a atteint le porte parole
du gouvernement a pris trois fois la
parole elle s'est exprimée à nouveau à
la mi journée le ministre de la santé a
lui aussi parlé ce matin l'exécutif est
sur tous les fronts pour prédire cent
mille cas d'ici la fin de l'année pour
accélérer la mise en place du pass
vaccinale pour dramatiser est ce que le
gouvernement patrick burke est en train
de préparer les esprits à de nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires et si oui
lesquelles selon vous vous aimeriez qu à
vous en tant que médecin
parce que j'ai mangé mon premier c'est
le renforcement de la vaccination bien
sûr c'est l'élément principal en deux le
respect des mesures barrières et en 3
mais ça c'est vraiment ce que personne
ne veut céder métaux de plus strictes
style de nouveau couvre-feu confinement
et ça plus personne n'en veut on est au
gouvernement justement il n'est pas en
train de préparer les esprits avec ses
prises de parole multiples en moins de
24 heures la écouter alors je sais pas
il faut regarder ce qui se passe un peu
et ailleurs et des pays qui ont de
l'avancé sur nous je pense à la norvège
la hollande au danemark à l'angleterre
pour regarder comment ça évolue chez eux
le virus diffuse de façon très
importante il faut maintenant qu'on voit
si ce virus créé des dégâts importants
on n'en sait rien on a on n'a pas de
données très précises statut si ça crée
des dégâts importants on ne raconte
d'autre choix que de refaire un
confinement on est bien d'accord si les
dégâts sont supportables il faudra
renforcer la vaccination des mesures
barrières le pass and i ter ne passe
vaccinale se sont tus mesure qui marche
bien l'an passé à la même époque on nous
disait papy mamie ne mangent de la bûche
dans la cuisine un an après tout le
monde ou presque est doublement vacciner
voire triplement vacciner et en israël
on parle même de quatrième dose comment
expliquer un tel marasme malgré les
vaccins
c'est pas eu un peu une course en avant
pour essayer de renforcer l'immunité
encore et encore et encore face à un
virus qui mute un petit peu et qui peut
perdre un peu de son efficacité et dont
le vaccin peut perdre un peu
d'efficacité heureusement pour l'instant
le mitron ne semble pas mettre à défaut
les trois doses vaccinales donc deux os
normale et la dose booster qui fait
monter les taux d'anticorps de façon
très importante
ça ne semble pas le montrer donc pour
l'instant on ne parle pas de quatrième
dose bien portants par contre que tout
le monde le maximum de gens aient
rapidement la fameuse troisième dose qui
édite deux boosters parce qu'elle peut
faire augmenter de façon très importante
le taux d'anticorps et nous protéger
encore de faux pour quelques mois
aujourd'hui c'est le coup d'envoi de la
vaccination pour les 5 11 ans il ya un
sondage et lab pour l'express bfm et sfr
qui vient d'être sorti et qui dit que
68% des parents sont contre les enfants
ont très peu de chances de deux fermes
des formes graves du coc vide alors
pourquoi les parents voudraient etienne
vacciner leurs enfants
la vaccination est à la fois une défense
individuelle et surtout une défense
collective on a intérêt à faire baisser
la pression virale par tous les moyens
le virus en général hello micron
actuellement diffuse très vite chez les
jeunes on a intérêt à calmer un peu ce
virus en vaccinant le maximum de gamin
même s'ils n'en tire pas un bénéfice
énorme parce qu'ils font plus de formes
graves est en cours n'en sais rien il
semblerait que le micro ça plus agressif
chez les jeunes enfants il ya plus de
syndrome pims il ya plus de maladies
graves que avec les variants antérieur
donc je crois qu'il s'est pourtant les
spectateurs le syndrome pin's vous
pouvez l'expliquer aux c'est un syndrome
de défaillance polyviscérale donc tous
les organes souffre énormément le coeur
le foie les reins et c'est les gamins
sont parfois obligés d en réanimation
donc c'est vraiment une maladie très
grave coin etc c'est connu ça a été
décrit avec les premiers variant il
semblerait que le taux d'incidence de ce
pimms soit plus grand avec le mitron et
donc je crois que ça remet vraiment sur
le devant l'indication de la vaccination
pour protéger des gamins parce que ce
virus n'est pas aussi anodin je pense
qu'on peut le penser la lâchait sont le
sait a donné un lundi son aval donc pour
la vaccination des 5 11 en mai une
vaccination je cite ni exigible ni
obligatoire est ce que simplement le
fait de dire ces deux mots ce que c'est
pas justement préparer là aussi des
esprits à une future obligation
ben moi je suis partisan de la
vaccination obligatoire en tant que
médecin c'est évident le vaccin les
vaccins en général ce sont nos meilleurs
outils thérapeutiques et de loin donc on
va pas se priver de cet outil là
d'autant plus qu'on a la chance de
l'avoir donc moi je suis fervent
défenseur de la vaccination obligatoire
pour tout le monde donc bien sûr
peut-être que c'est des éléments de
langage qui prépare à sa merci patrick
vague d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que votre médecin généraliste
stern à sa merci